the nfc odds for
who will win the pro football
championship aka super bowl san
francisco plus 900 still trailing the
chiefs and the ravens but the 49ers were
just great last year wire to wire a
dominant team in the nfc and i expect
them to be very good this year let's
pivot the conversation as we do 13
questions 13 days away from the start of
the 2020 season shireen williams and
mike florio here with you for another
half hour or so on this friday morning
number seven of our 13 questions shireen
will tom brady have a career
rejuvenation in tampa we mentioned last
segment as you know we look at whether
or not cam newton is going to be an
upgrade upgrade over tom brady 2019
easier to do than upgrade over tom brady
2018 2017 2016 etc
well he certainly has better weapons
than he had in new england no question
about that over the last few years with
mike evans and chris godwin and gronk is
back and oj howard you just start going
down the list uh it's incredible i don't
know how you double we talked about this
a lot who you double who you don't
double is more what it's going to be but
he's going to have a lot of choices to
throw the ball down the field can he
still get the ball down the field he is
43 years old and we know you don't get
better with age in the nfl that
certainly doesn't happen father time
catches up with everybody eventually
it's going to catch up with tom brady i
think he's got something left i don't
know if it's going to be a total
rejuvenation i don't think we're going
to see an mvp like year but i think he
has enough to lead the bucks to the
super bowl
that this is a team that's pretty loaded
you know he got shaq barrett on the
defense and a pretty good defense over
there with vance joseph and
i think they're pretty good and it you
know it could be something that peyton
manning did in his last year in denver
you know it wasn't a peyton manning led
super bowl but he got but the team got
to the super bowl with peyton manning as
their quarterback and it could be
something like that with tom brady
although i think he has a little bit
more left than peyton manning did in his
last year
well and and the thing that happened to
peyton manning was he got hit you get
hit you get hurt and i've been told for
a few years now tom brady will be able
to throw the way he throws the football
into his 50s the question is the legs
when the legs begin to go you begin to
absorb more physical contact and the
more physical contact you absorb the
more likely you are to become injured
and we've seen it from time to time with
brady and this is not in any way a
commentary on toughness because the game
has evolved to the point where
we understand the motivation to live to
see another play and tom brady will bail
out there was the play against the
steelers a couple of years ago there was
a debate that lingered for days was he
trying to throw it away was he trying to
throw to a receiver he was bailing out
and getting rid of the football because
he was about to get hit and then in the
chiefs game last year with the game on
the line fourth down threw the ball to
the end zone to julian edelman misfired
because
he bailed out he ducked and covered
because frank clark was bearing down on
him he's now at a point in his career
where some of these guys who are chasing
him are less than half his age they are
young enough to be his child that's how
old he is and the legs will go and look
if this bruce aryan's offense
no risk it no biscuit hold the ball
throw the ball down the field i don't
know
that we're going to see a whole lot of
deep drops i don't know that we're going
to see tom brady holding the ball three
or four seconds i think it's going to be
almost like
the greatest show-offs on turf from
1999. i hate to make this comparison but
remember how kurt warner would just
basically be throwing the ball as he's
making his drop it was quick it was
arena football it was the balls out the
balls out the balls out the balls out
that's what i think they need to do this
year to keep tom brady healthy shireen
he has to get rid of the ball as quickly
as he possibly can as many plays as he
possibly can
well one thing we know for sure mike is
they've gone from one extreme to the
other mr 30 30 they're not gonna have 30
interceptions this year tom brady had
eight last season he's not going to turn
the ball over so that's going to be one
thing that's going to help the boxes
they're not going to consistently be
turning the ball or on offense which is
what they did last season we saw the
pick sixes just killed them game after
game after game they're not going to
have that we know that for sure can
brady stay healthy can he stay upright
can he make enough throws down the field
are those legs still good all those
things will determine ultimately how far
this bucks team goes
but he's got more weapons than he's ever
had and if he's got anything at all left
it will be a sort of rejuvenation for
him
he's never had on the field two guys who
need to be double covered he's got mike
evans and he's got gronk and if gronk is
healthy what are you gonna do right if
gronk bruce aaron's a coach of the team
and i'll defer to bruce he's around he's
been around he's seen gronk he's there
he's got access if this is the rob
gronkowski of five years ago well it was
four or five years ago where the main
talking point going into the first game
of the season was how in the hell are
the steelers going to cover rob
gronkowski and of course they ultimately
tried covering him with no one a couple
of times we know that doesn't work
but uh yeah if gronk is the guy that he
used to be
tom brady's gonna have one of those two
guys single covered at at best on uh
every given play all right number eight
how much does drew brees have left in
the tank for the new orleans saint
shireen
oh it's a great question because i i
think he started to lose it last year
you know he's 41 years old and i didn't
see the same breeze that i've seen in
the past now the completion percentage
is still way up there he led the league
yet again over 74 he owns that nfl
record for completion percentage in a
season he can do that very very well but
i didn't see the same throws out of tom
out of drew brees that i saw in the past
with him and i i just think his arm has
started to go a little bit but sean
payton's a genius i'm a big fan of sean
payton back dating back to his
pre-dallas days but especially when he
was here and i got to know him i just
think he's a great offensive mind it may
be the offense that you were talking
about for the bucks maybe that's the way
new orleans goes with getting the ball
out quicker to try to protect drew brees
and and not have to throw the ball down
the field because that's something that
i don't think he can do much of anymore
and they also have taysom hill and they
also have jameis winston by the way
again going back to sean payton being an
offensive genius i guarantee you those
guys are going to be used in games and
they're going to be used to throw the
ball they need to throw the ball down
the field it may be one of those guys
doing it
the moment that really underscored the
lack of a deep ball for drew brees for
me came in the 2018 playoffs against the
eagles first play of the game two weeks
to get ready here we go we've dialed it
up it's going to be a deep throw and he
under throw it and and there's been
something missing from that long ball
for drew brees that's why taysom hill's
the guy who throws it now and brees said
at the start of training camp that he
spent some time working on the deep ball
i don't know what you can do at 41
to be able to throw the ball farther
than you otherwise can because again
father time is undefeated so i think
he's got enough left in the tank to run
the base offense but we will see
taysom hill firing the ball deep and i
think the challenge is as you get taysom
hill on the field more and i think we're
gonna see him on the field more now that
they're paying him eight figures per
year
getting him the ball in a situation
where maybe before the play you didn't
think the deep pass was coming and
during the play it develops in a way
that yeah here's taysom hill and he's
going to fire at 50 or 60 yards down the
field all right uh question number nine
how do the 49ers avoid the hangover that
comes from being up 10 points with seven
minutes left in the super bowl and
blowing the game to the chiefs
that's a tough one mike because we
haven't seen it done very much in the
recent nfc teams that have lost atlanta
carolina the rams you know they struggle
the next year and and i think this could
be a case where the 49ers struggle i
think what they have going for them is
kyle shanahan because i i think he's an
outstanding young coach i think he'll
he'll keep the team motivated i think
he'll come up with some different things
on offense but it is real the hangover
is real uh it you know history shows you
that that it's hard to get over that
hangover especially when you lose a
large lead like that they had in the
fourth quarter and couldn't close it out
it's going to be very difficult and and
they're in a tough division which makes
it even more difficult
for them to overcome that i'm not going
to be at all surprised if they don't win
the division now i'd be surprised if
they don't get into the playoffs with
the extra playoff team but i'm not going
to be surprised if they don't win that
division with the division that they're
in
i'm going to echo a point that i made
earlier this year when kyle shanahan was
doing the state of the franchise his
appearance and i know a lot of his
contrived it's for the benefit of the
fans and what's the state of the
franchise and you know he made the
comment we need to get back to where we
were up 10 with seven minutes to go in
the super bowl and you know my reaction
to that is that's
the hard part the easy part is holding
that lead for the final seven minutes of
the super bowl it's ridiculously
difficult to get back to where you were
when that lead evaporated especially in
that division they had to go week by
week and grind it out and fight and
scratch and claw
to get to week 17
and barely beat the seattle seahawks
they lose that game to the seahawks
they're the five seed in the nfc and
they're not going to the super bowl as
the five seed not without those two home
games those two home games made all the
difference for the 49ers to get to the
super bowl so i think that there is a
real possibility that they don't win the
division this year and if they don't win
the division they're not going back to
the super bowl that doesn't mean they're
not going to be back in the super bowl
soon i think they've got a great roster
but look there's only two teams
uh in recent years that have lost a
super bowl not in recent years i think
ever right it was the dolphins right in
the early 70s and it was the patriots a
couple of years ago to lose the super
bowl and to come back the next year
and win the super bowl that is a rare
rare accomplishment and uh actually i
think the cowboys also did it right they
lost to the colts with the jim o'brien
field goal and then they came back and
make the dolphins the next year so
actually it happened twice right
dolphins lose to the cowboys after the
cowboys lost to the colts and then the
dolphins beat washington and then it
went all those years until the patriots
did it losing to the eagles and beating
the falcons it's not easy to do
to go back to zero and zero like rich
basaccia told you and do it all over
again when you ultimately didn't get the
prize the last time around and
everybody's gonna be gunning for the
49ers all right let's stay in the nfc
east for question around nfc west excuse
me for question number 10 will the
seahawks finally unleash
russell wilson he has said let's treat
every quarter like the fourth quarter
let's not wait until the game is almost
out of our reach before they say russell
go save us will they finally do it
shireen
it's amazing to me mike that you know we
talked recently about hall of famers
playing in the nfl right now and and to
me he looks like a hall of famer he's
been one of the best quarterbacks in the
league since he came into the league as
a third round draft pick and took over
the starting job
but it is amazing that he's never made
the all-pro he's never been an mvp
rarely he hasn't gotten an mvp vote as
we know as we've talked about he's never
thrown for over 4 200 yards i mean
that's the most he's ever had is just
over 4 200 yards so he's never thrown
for 4 300 yards all those things are
amazing me it's time for the seahawks to
put this team in his hands and say
russell wilson you're our best player
you've proved it year after year after
year we're now going to turn control
over to you to lead us and show us the
way uh and really put it on him to do it
because i think he can do it i still
think he's one of the best quarterbacks
i'd put him in the top five if not the
top three quarterbacks in this league
but they've got to give them an
opportunity to do that game after game
after game not just in the fourth
quarter when it when it when they have
to
yeah sims and i talked about it earlier
this week you buy the ferrari you use
the ferrari right 35 million a year use
this guy and all the talk about russell
wilson he said it again they acted like
it was a big deal oh he's going to play
toys 45 he's been saying that for years
how long will that be with the seahawks
that's the real question because if they
don't eventually let this guy blossom as
a passer when he sees all these other
younger quarterbacks who he is confident
whether he's right or wrong he's
confident he's as good if not better
than patrick mahomes kyler murray lamar
jackson let me show it
let's not hand off handoff handoff
handoff let me show what i can do while
i still have the skills to do it because
every year he's getting closer and
closer to that point where the
discussion is going to be along the
lines of our current conversations about
drew brees and tom brady all right uh
speaking of a guy who is closer to the
drew brees and tom brady category than
russell wilson when it relates to age
question 11
is this going to be given what the
packers did in the first round of the
draft and the rest of the draft and not
getting help for aaron rodgers but
instead drafting his replacement in
round one trading up to do it is this
going to be in aaron rodgers revenge
tour in 2020
well first of all i hear jordan love has
not looked that great in practice he
struggled
perhaps more than a rookie first round
pick should struggle so i don't know how
much aaron rodgers is currently looking
over his shoulder but we know that he
thrives on motivation and this is
motivation for him he's made that quite
clear the them using the first round
draft pick on jordan love so
aaron rodgers has a chance to do some
really big things this season and i'm
not at all going to be surprised if he's
not in that mvp conversation and perhaps
wins the mvp award at the end of the
season because i do think he's motivated
i do think he thrives on motivation and
chip on his shoulder
yeah i absolutely agree with that in
last year
when the report came out from tyler dunn
of bleacher report about the dysfunction
between rogers and mike mccarthy
one of the observations in the aftermath
of that from ceo mark murphy was maybe
this will be a good thing right
maybe having people upset will will
provide some external motivation and it
worked they went 13-3 and they almost
got to the super bowl and i can't help
but wonder whether or not this is a
little mad scientist routine by mark
murphy to to get aaron rodgers
even more motivated in what will be his
final years with the green bay packers
it is astounding to me though to think
that they spent a first round pick on a
quarterback who they can control for
five years when you consider the option
but at some point
it's going to be the baton being taken
from if need be aaron rodgers and handed
to jordan love but as you said it's not
going to happen any time soon love has
been raw and that makes it even more of
an affront to aaron rodgers the point
that was made in the aftermath of the
draft when it was brett favre
essentially being aaron rodgers
surrogate on radio appearances it's not
like tuatanga viloa fell into their laps
this is a guy they traded up to get who
is regarded as a project not as a can't
miss
nfl quarterback like rogers was when the
packers drafted him in 2005 after he
fell into the 20s so there is a
difference there and that may make aaron
rodgers even more upset question number
12
can mike mccarthy the new coach of the
dallas cowboys fully harness all of the
talent that he has especially on offense
jason garrett didn't get it done in the
10 years he had to get it done and they
gave him plenty of talent there's no
question about that it's an ultra
talented team we talked about teams with
thousand yard players they had three
last year and have added cd lamb to that
equation the biggest question may be how
do they spread the ball around to those
four players who need to get the ball
and and also at tight end they are
raving about blake jarwin and how he's
doing so now you have five players
you're trying to get uh the ball to so
that may be the biggest thing for the
cowboys on offense but the offense
wasn't a question last year of getting
yards they led the league in yards it
was getting touchdowns it was scoring in
the red zone and those sorts of things
kellem war still the offensive
coordinator but i think mike mccarthy
will be better in his ear to tell him
what to do to make those changes that
need to be made in the red zone to get
them more touchdowns than field goals
when they get down there
and and i think they'll be better on
offense this season and i think they'll
be better on defense this season and and
probably a little bit more scheme-wise
difficult to read so i i do think
coaching is going to make a difference
for the cowboys now
how much of a difference is it going to
make i think that's the question this is
a team that we know hasn't been to the
nfc championship much less the super
bowl since 1995 which is their last
super bowl championship this is a team
that has failed in the playoffs even
when they've had the best record in the
nfc they failed to get it done at home
so that's the question can they get it
done in the playoffs and that still
remains to be seen
and even though we're focusing on
football this hour one of the
non-football questions from last hour
spills over we talked about
coaches who may not be properly reading
the room and going forward with practice
and mike mccarthy look i'll defer to him
but he's new to that room
and that he he had some quotes earlier
today about whether there was a vote
yesterday to practice or today to
practice he said we didn't get into that
we talked about a number of other things
but practicing or not practicing was not
a topic they had a team meeting
yesterday after practice jerry jones
wasn't there they expect him to be there
soon the players are looking forward to
talking to him these non-football issues
could become a football disruption and
it's going to be a challenge for mike
mccarthy to handle it properly and he
may end up being
the liaison the buffer the go-between
to bridge
whatever disconnect may exist between
jerry jones stephen jones and players
who may be feeling very very strongly
about exercising their right
to peacefully protest during the anthem
that's something that mccarthy i think
may be finding himself in the middle of
shireen
yeah you wonder if mike mccarthy knew
what he was getting into and ron rivera
knew what he was getting into and if
they would still take those jobs if they
had those opportunities but yeah
mccarthy had to know that that jerry
runs the organization and how it's run
i'm sure he talked to enough people but
he's got a big job on his hands now and
he can't let that spill over into the
locker room and he's gonna have to play
the part of liaison and keep this team
happy uh and keep him on the field and
in performing and it's a tough job but i
do think they're over the next two weeks
is very important for the cowboys with
what happens internally within the
locker room and meeting with jerry jones
whatever that entails but i think the
next two weeks are crucial to how this
team is going to take the field on
opening day mentally
and are they going to be right
last one real quickly does the kirk
cousins victory over the saints in the
playoffs last year mean we will see a
higher level of play for him especially
in big games this season
it better be with what they've paid him
right so i yeah i i think kirk cousins
learned something from that and i do
think we're going to see a different and
better kirk cousins this season
that game got a lot of guys paid it got
cousins paid it got zimmer paid mike
zimmer the head coach he got rick
spielman the gm paid the one guy that
hasn't gotten paid yet
running back dalvin cook who had a
couple of touchdowns in that game and
we'll see if they can work out a deal
with him before the season begins they
open at home with no fans against the
green bay packers in just 16 days what a
way to start the season your rival one
of your biggest rivals in your brand new
still fairly brand new still smells like
a new car stadium with no fans there to
create the kind of noise that has given
the vikings a home field advantage ever
since they moved indoors all those years
ago
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports